PROFESSOR: So let's
get set to state
Hall's theorem in a way that
doesn't mention boys and girls.
But let's remember the
girl-boy setup to start.
So the general setup
is a bipartite graph H.
And a bipartite graph has
two sets of vertices--
the girl vertices
and the boy vertices.
Formally, there's a set L of H,
called the left vertices of H,
and a set R of H, called
the right vertices of H.
The vertices of H altogether
are L of H union R of H.
Both of these are non-empty.
And they don't overlap.
Then the edges of H have
the property that they only
go between L of H
and R of H. That
is the definition of
a bipartite graph.
Now, we're interested in a
matching in a bipartite graph.
So let's be precise
again of what's
a matching without having
to mention boys and girls
and like.
A match is a total injective
function from the left vertices
to the right vertices.
So that means every L vertex,
or girl, has a match m of L
that is on the other side.
And we need this total injective
function, match function m,
to follow the edges.
What does follow the
edges mean precisely?
It simply means that
the edge l m of l
is a legitimate edge
of H. Another way
to say that is that the graph
of this total injective function
is a subset of the edges of H.
So we can state the
no-bottleneck condition,
Hall's condition, as follows.
If the size of S is less
than or equal to its image
under the edges, for
every set of left vertices
H, that's called Hall's
condition, that the size of S
is less than or equal to
the image of S for every S,
then there is a match.
So this is a way of precisely
stating Hall's theorem.
No boys and girls mentioned.
We'll be comfortable going
back to the boy-girl language,
because it's more memorable
and easier to talk about.
But just for the record, we have
now formally stated, defined
bipartite graphs, matches
in bipartite graphs,
and Hall's theorem
really that there
is a match when Hall's condition
is satisfied without mentioning
boys and girls.
The puzzle is, how do you verify
that there are no bottlenecks?
It's pretty hard.
The bottleneck
condition involves
checking that every
subset S of L of H
satisfies this
cardinality condition.
And there are a lot
of subsets of L of H
relative to the size of the
graph, exponentially many.
So we can ask, how do you verify
that there are no bottlenecks?
Well, it turns out in
logarithms classes,
you will learn a fairly
efficient matching procedure,
runs about quadratically,
for finding
perfect matches when they exist.
But there is one
particular special case
that ensures no bottlenecks
that we'll be making use
of several times in the term.
And that special situation
is when it turns out
that every girl
likes at least d boys
and every boy likes
at most d girls.
This is called a
degree-constrained graph.
If a graph is
degree constrained,
then there are no bottlenecks.
So this condition that each
girl likes at least d boys
and every boy likes
at most d girls
could have been
rephrased as saying
that the minimum
degree of the girls
is greater than or equal to
the maximum degree of the boys.
But I think expressing it
in terms of d maybe makes
it a little clearer.
Let's prove this.
I'm going to prove
that, if you have
a degree-constrained
bipartite graph,
then it, in fact,
satisfies Hall's condition.
There are no bottlenecks.
So we have that,
if every girl likes
at least d boys and every
boy likes to most d girls,
there are no bottlenecks.
The proof goes as follows.
Let's look at some
arbitrary set S of girls.
And suppose that
the total number
of edges that are incident
to S has cardinality e.
There are e edges that touch
vertices in S. Well, that
tells us that since
every vertex in S
has at least d edges out-- maybe
more-- d times the size of S
has to be less than or equal
to the total number of edges
coming out of S.
Likewise, all of the
edges that come out of S
go, by definition, into E of
S. And each vertex in E of S
can only absorb
d edges, d girls.
So that means that the
total number of edges
absorbed by E of S-- that
is, at most d times E of S--
had better be bigger
than the number
of edges that have
to be absorbed e.
So we get that d
times the size of S
is less than or equal to the
total number of edges incident
to S, which is less
than or equal to d
times the total number
vertices in E of S.
Well, I'll cancel the d's.
And we have that
the size of S is
less than or equal to
the size of its image.
That's the definition of a
bottleneck-- The violation
of that would be a bottleneck.
This says, there's
no bottlenecks.
And we have proved the
degree-constrained condition
is sufficient to verify
Hall's condition.
And by Hall's theorem, it's
sufficient to guarantee
that there is a match.
Now, there's a lot of
graphs with matches
that are not degree-constrained.
This is not an if
and only if theorem.
It's just a sufficient condition
that comes up often enough
that it's worth mentioning.
Degree-constrained implies
Hall's condition is satisfied,
which implies that
there's a perfect match.
So let's turn now to the
general case of Hall's theorem.
And let's talk about
proving Hall's theorem.
Hall's theorem says that
if there's no bottleneck,
then there is a match.
So let's begin by
setting up a lemma that
will play a crucial role.
The strategy for
proving it is basically
going to be to try to break
the problem of finding
a match for a large
set of vertices
into sub problems
of finding matches
for smaller sets of vertices.
And by strong induction,
Hall's condition
will apply to the
subsets and will win.
Let's look at that
more carefully.
So let's begin by
supposing that there
are no bottlenecks in some
bipartite graph H. Well,
in particular, if there's
no bottlenecks anywhere,
then if you restrict yourself
to some set S of girls,
no subset of that set S is
going to have a bottleneck,
obviously, because a
bottleneck within S
would be a bottleneck
within the whole graph.
So that part's trivial.
What's not trivial and takes
a little bit of arguing
is that suppose you have a
set of girls with the property
that the number of boys that
are compatible with that set
of girls is exactly the
same as the number of girls.
So technically, the size of S
is equal to the size of E of S.
In that case, we can argue that
there aren't any bottlenecks
within the complement of S
and the complement of E of S
either.
Well, let's look at a picture
to illustrate what's going on.
So here we have a
bipartite graph.
And there's S and its
image on the right E of S.
And we know that
a bottleneck here
would imply a bottleneck
in the whole graph.
What we want to argue is that
a bottleneck in the complement
of S would imply a bottleneck
in the complement of E of S.
So there's the
complement of E of S.
And there's the complement of S.
Now, notice that some edges that
come out of the complement of S
may very well go into
the E of S. That is,
this would be a point
that's both in E of S
and in E of S complement.
But we're not allowed
to use that point,
because we're trying
to find a match only
within S bar and E of S bar.
And what we're really
trying to argue
is that a bottleneck here
would imply a bottleneck
in the whole graph.
So let's see if
we can argue this.
We want to claim that there's
no bottleneck between S
bar any E of S bar given that
there's no bottleneck anywhere
and when S and E of
S are the same size.
So let's suppose that we
had a set T over here that
was a subset of S bar.
And let's look at its
image over here in orange.
So we've got that the image of
this set T, when we restrict it
just to the part that's
in the complement of S--
notice I'm leaving
out this point here.
I'm not taking the
image of T. I'm
taking the image of T restricted
to the points that are not
in the image of S. And
what I want to know
is, could that
cause a bottleneck?
After all, I've left
out some points that
used to be included in the image
of T. And so the image of T
might have been bigger than T
because of those extra points
that I'm leaving out,
I have to be sure
that that doesn't happen.
Could there be a
bottleneck that has
been created by these
points that I've left out?
Could there be a bottleneck
in E of T intersection,
a complement to E of S.
Could that orange guy
be a bottleneck?
Well, if it was a
bottleneck, then
I'd have a bottleneck
in the whole graph.
And that's because S and E of S
are the same size, because all
I do is, if I had
a bottleneck there,
I would take this set T along
with S and this set orange
along with E of S, and
that would be a bottleneck.
Because now, if you
look at the size of T,
I've added the same
amount to the size of T
as I've added to that orange
set, because E of S and S
are the same size.
So if this orange part
was smaller than T,
then orange part along with E
of S is smaller than T union S.
And that defines a bottleneck
in the whole graph.
So again, if there
was a bottleneck
in here caused by
restricting images
to the complement
of E of S, it means
there was a bottleneck
in the whole graph.
If there's no bottleneck
at all, then indeed,
there's no bottleneck
in this other part
of the complement of S and
the complement of E of S.
And this gives me a hook
on proving Hall's theorem,
because that's
basically the way I'm
going to split the problem into
two separate matching parts.
So let's now proceed
to prove that if there
are no bottlenecks in a graph,
then there's a perfect match.
And it's going to be
by strong induction
on the number of girls.
So case one is the case
that we just examined,
that there's a non-empty subset
of girls-- a proper subset,
not all the girls--
some subset of girls
who-- another way to say it
is there's a subset of girls
that's not empty and its
complement is not empty either.
And the size of S is the
same as the size of E of S.
That is, the number
of boys that are
compatible with
this set of girls
is exactly the same size
as this set of girls.
Well, if there's
going to be a match,
there has to be
one in that subset.
And by the lemmas, if there's
no bottlenecks anywhere,
there's no bottlenecks
when I restrict myself to
just S and E of S. And
also by the previous Lemma,
there's no bottleneck in the
complement of S restricted
to the vertices in E of S.
So this is a new
bipartite graph,
where I'm using S for the
left vertices and E of S
for the right vertices.
And here, I'm using
the complement
of S for the left vertices
and the complement of E of S
for the right vertices.
And the previous lemma says
that if there's no bottlenecks
overall, there's no
bottlenecks in either
of these two restricted graphs.
So what I can do now is,
by induction, since there's
no bottlenecks in S, E of
S, I can find a match there.
So I can match up
all of the girls in S
with compatible boys in E
of S. And I can match up
all of the girls
that are not in S,
in the complement
of S, with boys
that I haven't used already.
And there will be a
perfect match there.
And then these two
separately will
provide a match for the
entire set of left vertices--
S union the complement of S
will be all of the vertices.
And these two matchings
don't overlap.
So combining them gives
a complete matching.
That knocks off this case.
That's the nice case, where
I can find some subset
with the number
of boys is exactly
equal to the number of
girls, which means that that
has to work by itself.
And I worked that one by itself
and what's left over by itself.
And that's how I can
find an overall match.
The second case is
that there isn't
any set of girls, which
are compatible with exactly
the same number of boys.
Well, since Hall's
condition holds,
that means that
every set of girls
actually has to be compatible
with a larger set of boys
than the number of girls.
That is, for every
set S, the size of S
is strictly less
than the size of E
of S for every non-empty
and proper subset S.
Well in that case,
actually finding a match
is easy, because
now I've got slack.
What I can do is just pick an
arbitrary girl-- call her g--
and she's got to be compatible
with at least one boy,
because there's no bottlenecks.
In fact, in this
case, she'll actually
be compatible with
these two boys.
But all we need is one boy.
Since there's no bottlenecks,
if I pick a girl,
she's got to be
compatible with some boy.
And I'm just going to
arbitrarily match her
with that boy-- match g with b.
Now, the consequence of
that is that, if I now
remove g and b from
the graph, I am
left with a graph in
which at worst I've
shrunk the set E
of S by that girl
that I've matched with B,
which means that E of S, which
used to be strictly greater than
S has gone down by at most one.
It's still greater than
or equal to E of S.
So I'm left that in
the graph after I've
removed this g paired
with an arbitrary b
that she's compatible
with, I'm left
with a graph that
satisfies Hall's condition
that has one fewer girl vertex.
And so it has no bottlenecks.
And therefore, it has a match.
And that match in
the sub graph, where
I've taken out g and b, when
I put back the match, when
I add the part of
g matching with b,
it's a match for
the whole graph.
And that's how I get it.
That completes the
proof of Hall's theorem.